school's over for the day and Yosef is
back home it's an unusual living
arrangement Yosef who's from Egypt is
living with three Catholic nuns these
franciscan sisters in the Western
Germantown of OPA have taken in Yosef
and his family they had to leave Egypt
because they're Christians and were
persecuted there the convent is a
livelier place now that an entire family
is living there the sisters are really
nice they're helping me to learn German
they're always ready to help me this
Vista Emma's organ on Emma helfen
recently I guess al-islamiya da they
haven't been here very long about two
weeks it's changed our lives there are
new people in our home now it just
sounds different now when we hear
something we just figure it's one of the
family members upstairs yeah oh yeah
doesn't the obin Pope Francis would
approve of what the nuns are doing he
says the church should set a good
example that includes sheltering
refugees but that would be a problem for
these Dominican friars there are only a
few of them in this monastery and many
of them are elderly father David would
like to host some refugees but he can't
yeah l to the Buddha some of the friars
here are old or ill Lida and it's our
job to take care of themself I'm starin
good but that doesn't mean that we don't
care about the refugees unselfishly some
German priests and nuns have heard the
Pope's message and the Dominicans in
Cologne are helping the refugees with
language courses and social support
here in the basement of st. Theodore's
church in Cologne father France Moira
and his team are getting ready to
distribute food to the needy many people
in this part of town depend on food
donations even more so since large
numbers of refugees have been arriving
the parish has also been able to provide
housing we are 29 yawen a year ago we
took in a family from Kosovo they had
eight kids including a newborn I think
it's great that the Pope is doing the
same now a lot of parishes have acted
even before the Pope's message hi loon
who's from Syria is repairing bicycles
for other refugees he's nearly 70 years
old and he's been in Germany for nearly
two years he lost everything when he
fled Syria ha begun I worked for 43
years and now it's all gone I lost two
homes a shop and an office but hyland is
glad to be in Germany where he feels
safe and since this parish helped him he
now wants to help the parish the
Franciscans say that helping refugees
whether they're Christians or Muslims is
just part of being a good Catholic the
nuns here say that the church is
changing thanks to Pope Francis is a
leader Jesus went to the fringes of
society and the Pope is doing exactly
the same he says that Christians should
also reach out to the fringes find the
needy and help them Yosef his parents
and his younger brother will finally
have a home this Christmas season
instead of an emergency shelter and for
that they can thank the Franciscan nuns
and the sisters believe that having a
few extra people around the content has
made their lives richer
you